i've told you before that there are sort
of like politician lies things like oh
uh reducing taxes on the rich stimulates
the job creators to get out there and
build businesses or something like that
it's completely untrue but it's the type
of thing that you actually have to
really do some research in order to sort
out and debunk and and counterpoint and
then there's the types of lies that
we've seen over the last six years from
the trumpian wing of the republican
party stuff like i don't know donald
trump is six foot three inches tall and
weighs 239 pounds that's an obvious lie
and speaking of that type of lie donald
trump's former doctor now republican
congressman ronnie jackson went on the
greg kelly uh reports show on newsmax
and claimed that donald trump is fitter
than 90 of people his age now it's
okay he's qualifying it by saying people
his age
but i can assure you that that's not
true and i've got the numbers to back it
up in a moment so let's listen to what
ronnie jackson had to say here and this
is the type of lie we're like why even
bother why bother with something so
obviously untrue obama and trump now
you're famous for uh extolling the
health virtues of
donald trump you did so publicly and a
lot of people are like oh man you're
over doing it
but actually let's face it
he is a very unique specimen i mean
anybody can see that he is 76 years old
he has the energy of a he's unique
that's true of a 16 year old
i don't think you were
do me a favor trump has the energy of a
16 year old yet when all the other world
leaders walked around in sicily trump
was driven on a golf cart real 16 year
old energy tell us about his health if
you don't mind
no he's in great health and people
wonder like why is he so healthy because
you know he's famous he doesn't have a
really great diet and he doesn't
exercise much uh you know than playing
golf and whatnot but
you gotta look at the you know his whole
life i mean during it throughout his
life he never drank he never smoked he
he led a pretty healthy life overall
compared to a lot of folks and so i
think that he's reaping the rewards of a
healthy life early on and he was in
great shape i mean i put him on the
treadmill did a cardiac stress test on
him he knocked now was the treadmill on
because just putting someone on a
treadmill that's off won't really stress
the body too much other than water i
mean he he was in the top 10
of of everyone in his age i mean he did
extremely well in his cardiac stress
test and he um he just you know he's
he's in great great health to be honest
with you and you know and i didn't
overdo it greg i'll point out that you
know i was very thorough in briefing
this physical exam something we have not
seen from the doctor at the white house
right now with regards to yep with joe
biden anything could be going on so this
is not fat shaming this is live shaming
this is livestream you don't have to lie
about everything you can say you like
trump's policy and you can say you think
trump was good for the country and you
like the way trump dealt with putin or
whatever but not lie that trump is one
of the healthiest people his age around
remember
um stress test cardiac stress test okay
there's an analysis that was done a
longitudinal analysis of cardiac stress
tests the median exercise time for men
trump's age
was 7 minutes and 22 seconds for a
maximum effort stress test
does anyone in my audience believe that
donald trump could do
maximum cardiac stress
for seven minutes and 22 seconds
and remember that's the median and we're
supposed to believe trump isn't median
but that he's in the top 10 percent
there are four stages to the cardiac
stress test
in among people among men trump's age
only one percent get to part four so
forget about part four
but fifteen percent of men
complete part three
they're telling us trump isn't just in
the top fifteen percent who would
complete the third part trump's in the
top 10 percent meaning of the 15 percent
that
get to complete part three
trump isn't even at the bottom of that
group give me a break guys it's it's
becoming north korea type stuff remember
all the things they would say about
kim jong-un and kim jong-il and with kim
jong-il it was you know he lifted a car
above his head i think that was one of
them i know that they said the first
time he played golf he played 18 holes
and got 18 holes in one um that double
rainbows like follow the guy around or
whatever that kim jong-il doesn't
defecate you know all sorts of he
created forms of energy and is also
failure
it's getting to be that that to that
degree and greg kelly you know his face
should be bright red maybe it is you
can't tell because of the makeup but
this is the type of stuff that would
make north korean propaganda uh news
anchors sort of blush so absolutely
pathetic and like just lie about things
that are difficult to obviously realize
are are being lied about uh this one is
tough tough to believe
all of us have had the experience of
dropping out of an important zoom call
because of a flaky wi-fi connection i've
had it when live streaming if you can
think of something more humiliating let
me know
something else i struggle with is when
i'm on the go
finding a good enough connection to
upload or download large video files
which i regularly need to do
what if you could fix all of this by
using more than one internet connection
at the same time
like the coffee shop wi-fi
and your mobile phone's connection
combining them into one super internet
connection that's faster and more
reliable our sponsor speedify is the
only app that can combine multiple
internet sources into one
fantastic
super connection like this this will
improve your live streaming your video
calling your gaming the web browsing
everything you do online
use speedify on all devices pc mac
iphone android linux works with any type
of internet connection simple to use
runs in the background i use it
everywhere especially when traveling and
it works great try speedify risk free
for seven days and get twenty percent
off go to speedify.com
pacman and use the code pacman click the
link down in the description